the modern denial of human nature number
10 on this week's New York Times
bestseller list in the book
professor Pinker argues that genetics is
a main component in human nature this
talk runs an hour and 25 minutes
thank you it's a real pleasure to be
here and be able to welcome you to our
home we also have a brand new building
at 550 which we're very proud of we just
moved into this summer before
introducing the speaker let me just take
this opportunity to introduce the
Academy's we call ourselves now the
National Academies I'm the president of
one of those the National Academy of
Sciences there are also two other
presidents upstairs National Academy of
Engineering and the Institute of
Medicine
together these three honorary
organizations have about 5,000 members
and then there is a operating arm of the
National Research Council that completes
this organization which is why we call
ourselves the National Academies because
it's too complicated
our major function besides honoring us
outstanding scientists and engineers is
to carry out studies for the US
government on any matter of science or
technology that they need advice on most
recently we completed a very major
effort publishing a important report on
science and technology for countering
terrorism an effort that involves some
120 volunteer committee members so it's
a major effort that's been playing
directly into the plans for the new
Department on Homeland Security well I
invite you to visit us not only in
person but on the web all of our reports
more than 2,500 of them are can be read
directly online today's lecture courses
by dr. Steven Pinker he's a professor of
psychology in the department of brain
and cognitive sciences at MIT the
Massachusetts Institute of Technology
his research has focused on visual
cognition and on the psychology of
language he turns out he received his
undergraduate degree from McGill
University and his PhD in psychology
from Harvard he was on the faculties of
Harvard and Stanford University's before
moving to MIT in 1982 he's received from
the second
on this stage year before I became
president in 1993 one of our wards
called the trollin research award which
we give to young investigators to
recognize unusual achievements it's only
ten years ago he's still pretty young
he's also won numerous other awards
including two from the American
Psychological Association and I think
very important the teaching Awards for
his service to students in the next
generation of researchers at MIT he is
of course written several best-selling
books he and he's won multiple awards
for to his popular science books the
language instinct and how the mind works
he also writes frequently for the
popular press including the New York
Times time slate and the New Yorker
magazines the the topic tonight of
course is the topic of his latest book I
don't really have to say the title it's
up there in a beautiful form it's
already been announced that he will be
doing a book signing but in addition
what wasn't announced there will be some
refreshments afterwards in the Great
Hall so please join me in welcoming dr.
Pinker thank you
thank you very much
everyone needs a theory of human nature
everyone has to do anticipate the
behavior of others that means we all
need theories tacit or explicit about
what makes people tick so much depends
on our theory of human nature we use our
conceptions of human nature to manage
our relationships to bring up our
children to control our own behavior the
assumptions about learning in our theory
of human nature guide our policies in
education its assumptions about
motivation guide our policies in law and
government and because a theory of human
nature delineates what we can achieve
easily what we can achieve only with
sacrifice or pain and what we cannot
achieve at all it affects our values
what we think we can reasonably strive
for as individuals and as a society it's
no surprise then that for millennia
theories of human nature were tied up in
religion and indeed the judeo-christian
theory of human life as it evolved over
centuries has commitments about what we
would today consider to be the
subject-matter of psychology and biology
for example in the judeo-christian
theory the mind is a system with a
number of faculties such as a capacity
for love a moral sense that presents us
with standards of right and wrong and an
ability to make choices which is free in
the sense that it isn't subject to the
laws of cause and effect we have free
will but it has an innate tendency to
choose sin
in this theory there's also a
explanation for how perception and
cognition work we know the world because
God designed our mental faculties to be
in synchrony with the way the world is
and there's even a theory of mental
health that mental health comes from
accepting God's purpose from loving God
and loving our fellow humans for that
God's sake now the judeo-christian
theory was motivated by particular
events narrated in the book of Genesis
for example the doctrine of free will
comes from the part of the Genesis story
that says that Adam and Eve were
punished for eating the fruit of the
tree of knowledge which implies that
they could have chosen otherwise which
implies that Free Will exists now today
no scientifically literate person can
believe that the events narrated in
Genesis literally took place and as a
result there's been a need for a
different grounding of human nature and
with the decline of fundamentalism I
think that modern intellectual life
tacitly committed itself to three
doctrines each of them associated with a
dead white male the first is the blank
slate or the tabula rasa commonly
associated with this man John Locke
although a search of his writings which
is now easy to do because they're all on
the internet shows that he actually
never used the expression blank slate
but here's what he did right he said let
us suppose the mind to be as we say
white paper void of all characters
without any ideas how comes it to be
furnished whence comes it by that vast
or which the busy and boundless fancy of
man has painted on it with an almost
endless variety whence has it all the
materials of reason and knowledge to
this I answer in one word from
experience now the blank slate is a
doctrine with a great deal of moral and
political appeal in Locke's time it
implied that dogmas such as the Divine
Right of Kings were not self-evident
truths implanted into our brains but
rather they had to be justified by
experiences that people shared
therefore could debate it undermines a
hereditary royalty and aristocracy who
could claim no more grounds for virtue
and wisdom if their minds started out as
blank as everyone else's and by the same
token and undermined the institution of
slavery because slaves could no longer
be held to be innately inferior or
subservient and this set of ideas is
nicely captured in the following cartoon
that I clipped out of the New Yorker
where one king says to another I don't
know anything about the bell curve but I
say heredity is everything now we
continue to see an influence of the
blank slate in modern intellectual life
and sometimes in unexpected places
psychology for most of the 20th century
tried to explain all human behavior
through a few simple mechanisms of
Association and conditioning the social
sciences try to explain all cultural and
social patterns through the idea of
socialization and culture as an
autonomous force here is an example from
a prominent social scientist of the 20th
century who wrote with the exception of
the instinct toward reactions in infants
to sudden withdrawals of support and to
sudden loud noises
the human being is entirely instinct
less man is men because he has no
instincts because everything he is and
has become he has learned acquired from
his culture from the man-made part of
the environment from other human beings
and that's a quote from the
anthropologist and public intellectual
Ashley Montagu here's another example of
how widespread the doctrine is I think
of a child's mind as a blank book during
the first years of his life much will be
written on the pages the quality of that
writing will affect his life profoundly
and that is a quote from Walt Disney
now there's a second doctrine that often
accompanies the blank slate which comes
from whose name comes from a poem by
John Dryden called the conquest of
Grenada I am as free as nature first
made man near the base laws of servitude
began when wild in woods the noble
savage ran now the noble savage is more
commonly attributed to this man the
French philosopher jean-jacques Rousseau
and here's what Rousseau actually did
right so many authors have hastily
concluded that man is naturally cruel
and requires a regular system of police
to be reclaimed
whereas nothing could be more gentle
than him in his primitive state the more
we reflect on this state the more
convinced we shall be that it was the
best for man and that nothing could have
drawn him out of it but some fatal
accident which should never have
happened the example of the savages
seems to confirm that mankind was formed
ever to remain in this condition that it
is the real youth of the world and that
all of ulterior improvements have been
so many steps in appearance towards the
perfection of individuals but in fact
towards the decrepit nough species now
you can't really understand someone
unless you know who he was arguing
against and indeed Rousseau was arguing
against so many authors and the main
author that he had in mind was this man
in particular the following passage here
by it is manifest that during the time
men live without a common power to keep
them all in awe they are in that
condition which is called war and such a
war is of every man against every man in
such condition there is no place for
industry because the fruit thereof is
uncertain and consequently no culture of
the earth no navigation no commodious
building no knowledge of the face of the
earth no account of time no arts no
letters no society and which is worst of
all continual fear and danger of violent
death and the life of man solitary poor
nasty brutish and short
this of course is the famous passage
from Thomas Hobbes as Leviathan
now that there's a great deal of Appeal
to the doctrine of the noble savage
which Rousseau used to oppose Hobbes if
in a state of nature we are naturally
peaceable then there's no need for a
domineering Leviathan a government and
police force to keep us from each
other's throats if we're basically nasty
then conflict is a permanent part of the
human condition whereas if we're
basically noble we can work for a
utopian society of the future children
are born savages so if the inner savage
in us is nasty then child-rearing must
be an arena of discipline and conflict
whereas if the Savage and us is
basically noble then child rearing
consists of providing children with
opportunities to develop their potential
like the blank slate the noble savage
has had a widespread influence in modern
intellectual life we see it in the
respect for everything natural and the
distrust of anything man-made natural
pharmaceuticals natural foods natural
yoghurt natural childbirth and so on we
see it in the unfashionable 'ti of
authoritarian styles of child-rearing we
see it in the understanding of social
problems as repairable defects in our
institutions as opposed to a more
traditional rule in which they would be
seen as part of the inherent tragedy of
the human condition and there's a third
doctrine that goes along with the noble
savage and the blank slate commonly
associated with this gentleman the
philosopher Rene Descartes Descartes
wrote when I consider my mind I cannot
distinguish any parts but apprehend it
to be clearly one and entire the
faculties of willing conceiving etc
cannot be said to be its parts for it is
one the same mind which employs itself
in willing and in feeling in and
understanding but it is quite otherwise
with corporeal objects for there is not
one of them imaginable but by me which
my mind cannot easily divide in two
parts this is sufficient to teach me
that the mind or soul of man is in
highly different from the body a
doctrine which several centuries later
was derided as the doctrine of the ghost
in the machine by the philosopher
Gilbert Ryle and no the police did not
invent that term in the album by that
name they stole it from rile the ghost
in the machine also has a great deal of
moral and emotional appeal people don't
like to think of themselves as glorified
gears and springs because machines are
insensate built to be used in disposable
whereas humans are sentient possessing
of dignity and rights and precious a
notion that seems to come out of the
doctrine that we have a soul that's
separate from the mechanism of the body
machines have some workaday purpose like
grinding horn or sharpening pencils
humans we like to think have a higher
purpose love worship good works
knowledge beauty machines follow the in
electable laws of physics whereas
behavior we like to think is freely
chosen with choice comes optimism about
possibilities for the future and with
choice comes responsibility and the
ability to hold other people accountable
for their behavior finally if the mind
is completely separate from the body
that holds out the hope that the mind
can survive the death of the body an
idea whose emotional appeal I think is
all too obvious like the other two
doctrines the ghost in the machine has
had a widespread influence freedom
dignity and responsibility are often
seen as incompatible with a biological
view of the mind which is commonly
condemned as being reductionist or
determinist now no one really knows what
these words mean but everyone knows that
there's something bad
we see it in a stem-cell debate where a
number of the theologians who weighed in
with President Bush the summer before
last couched the issue in terms of when
installment takes place which means that
perhaps the most promising medical
technology of the 21st century is
debated in terms of when the ghosts
first enters the machine and we see it
even in everyday thinking in speech as
when we talk about John's brain which
seems to presuppose some entity John
that's separate from the brain that it
owns and when journalists speculate
about brain transplants whereas in fact
they should really discuss body
transplants because as the philosopher
Dan Dennett once pointed out this is the
one such operation in which it's better
to be the donor than the recipient
now there's a big problem with a blank
slate and that is blank slates don't do
anything they would just sit there
forever
receiving inscriptions unless I had
something in their organization that
actively recombined the inscriptions on
the slate and use them in pursuit of
certain goals no one denies the
importance of learning socialization and
culture only a madman would say
everything is in the genes and that our
experience doesn't count the question
though is what are we born with that
allows us to learn and that allows
experience to leave its trace on future
behavior when Locke said there is
nothing in the intellect that was not
first in the census I think the perfect
reply came from live nights when he said
except for the intellect itself and
indeed it's this recognition that has
led to a number of threats to the blank
slate from contemporary sciences that
are studying the human mind for example
my own field cognitive science has
underscored that you need innate
mechanisms to do the learning to begin
with and that these innate mechanisms
are complex and multiple cognitive
scientists have argued that babies are
born with some concept of an object and
of causation that we have a number sense
a number of spatial representations that
allow the brain to keep track of the
environment and of objects in it a
theory of mind or intuitive psychology
by which we infer the mental states of
other people when we interact with them
and a language instinct that allows us
to communicate our thoughts and
executive systems of the frontal lobes
which receive information from many
parts of the brain and that affect
decisions that the rest of the brain and
body carry out evolutionary psychology
has challenged the blank slate by
showing that beneath all of the cultural
variation that anthropologists have
trumpeted for the last hundred years
there's also a bedrock of universals
emotions and behavior patterns
that are shared by all human beings
across the world 6,000 cultures recently
the anthropologist Donald Brown has
catalogued them he's found a good 300
universals everything from aesthetics
affection and ambivalence all the way
down to verbs violence vowels weaning
weapons and attempts to control the
weather
evolutionary psychology has undermined
the blank slate in another way by
showing that many human drives can't be
seen as ways in which people calculate
what's best for them in their own
day-to-day lives but rather can only be
understood as adaptations to an
ancestral environment in which we
evolved which may not be relevant to our
happiness and well-being today an
obvious example is our taste for sugar
salt and fat which has obvious health
consequences as many of us eat ourselves
into an early grave with too much junk
food but this it's perfectly
understandable why we have those tastes
those are precious nutrients and in an
environment in which they were in short
supply a taste for them would have been
adaptive now that we can crank out mass
quantities of the stuff our taste for
them hasn't changed and that does us
more harm than good a thirst for revenge
and a willingness to defend your
interests with violent defenses of one's
honor and lead to a great deal of
unnecessary suffering vendetta's blood
feuds cycles of revenge and so on but
were necessary in a world in which you
couldn't dial nine-one-one to get
leviathan to show up to settle your
scores for you and a reputation for
toughness was once owned only defense
against being a punching bag and less
obvious example is our desire for
attractive mates now number of years ago
the humorist Fran Lebowitz made a very
insightful observation about human
psychology she said people who marry
someone that they're attractive to are
making a terrible mistake
you really should marry your best friend
you like your best friend more than
you're likely to like anyone that you
happen to be physically attracted to you
don't pick your best friend because they
have a cute nose but that's all you're
doing when you're getting married you're
saying I'm gonna spend the rest of my
life with you because of your lower lip
now this is a puzzle and I think I think
the solution to it is demonstrations
that many of the anatomical signs of
beauty are in fact
advertisements of Health fertility and
fitness and in being attracted to people
with that facial geometry we're
maximizing the chances that our genes
will combine with the best other genes
neuroscience has shown that there is a
complex genetic patterning to the brain
although it's obvious that the brain has
a great deal of plasticity which is
necessary for us to learn and remember
there's also a great deal of complex
structure that's laid out in the course
of development in utero this is a
diagram of the primate visual system
it's not an oil refinery comprised of
some 50 distinct areas interconnected in
precise ways and it's not just the
overall cabling of the brain that is
partly under genetic control during
development but some of the fine
structure that makes one brain different
from another here's a diagram from a
recent study by the neuro biologists
Paul Thompson and his colleagues at UCLA
in which they measured using MRI the
distribution of gray matter in different
parts of the brain of a large sample of
people and they test it for correlations
between amounts of brain matter in
different parts of the cortex and
plotted them in false color so that
purple represents zero correlation and
colors that differ from purple that are
green and yellow and pink and so on
represents significant correlations now
if you peer people at random by
definition the correlations are zero and
here you see in a left view of the brain
right view of the brain top view of the
brain
what zero correlation looks like this is
what happens when a pair of people share
half their genes namely fraternal twins
you can see that large amounts of the
brain show correlations from one twin to
another and this is what happens when
you share all your genes there are areas
with very strong correlations and
virtually and large parts of the brain
show some correlation showing suggesting
that the shared genes build brains that
are more similar and it's likely that
these aren't just anatomical
Q's like your earlobes or your
fingerprints but have functional
consequences nicely summed up in this
cartoon also from The New Yorker by Chaz
Adams separated at Birth the malla for
twins meet accidentally
this is only somewhat of an exaggeration
studies of identical twins who were
separated at birth and then are tested
in adulthood showed that they often have
astonishing similarities my favorite
example being the twins one of whom was
brought up in as a Catholic in a Nazi
family in Germany the other was brought
up as a Jew in a family in Trinidad
nonetheless when they met each other as
adults it turned out that both of them
kept rubber bands around their wrists
both of them dipped buttered toast in
coffee both of them flushed the toilet
both before using it and after using it
and both of them liked to sneeze in
crowded elevators to watch everyone jump
now these admittedly are anecdotes but
they're never they've never been
documented in any pair of fraternal
twins separated at birth and reunited in
adulthood and they're corroborated by
the best measuring instruments known to
psychology that is that there are
enormous similarities among twins reared
apart which leads to what's sometimes
called the first law of behavioral
genetics which is that all behavioral
traits are partially heritable although
nowhere near completely the noble
savages also come under attack from
studies of of mind brain and behavior
behavioral genetics has shown that among
the traits that are heritable are
antagonism unconsciousness tendencies
towards violent crime and psychopathy
neuroscience has identified brain
mechanisms in among primates that are
associated with aggression evolutionary
psychology and anthropology have
underscored the ubiquity of conflict in
human societies just as we see elsewhere
in the animal kingdom now here is a
diagram of a graph of the percentage of
male deaths due to warfare in a variety
of societies that is if you're a male
what are the chances that you will die
at the hands of some other man as
opposed to dying peaceably in your bed
or by any other mean way the red bars
are from a variety of pre state
societies hunter gab
Hunter horticultural societies in the
New Guinea Highlands and the Amazon
rainforest and they ranged from about
10% to almost 60% the tiny little blue
bar at the lower left represents the
United States and Europe in the 20th
century and includes the statistics from
both world wars so not to put too fine a
point on it but when it comes to man in
a state of nature Hobbes was right
Rousseau was wrong now what about our
own society where we enjoy this
relatively low rate of death by violence
well here's a revealing question and
I'll pose it to you and I beg you not to
answer aloud but keep the answer to
yourself have you ever thought about
killing someone please don't answer well
psychologists are busybodies
and they have asked this question of
large samples of people and here's a
typical result about a third of men and
15% of women frequently think about
killing people they don't like
and about 3/4 of men and more than 60%
of women at least occasionally think
about killing people they don't like
them and many of you are probably
thinking yeah and the rest are liars the
ghost in the machine has also come under
attack a cognitive science has shown
that intelligence doesn't require some
ghostly substance it's not some act of
magic but it can be explained in
mechanistic terms that one can think of
beliefs as a kind of information
thinking as a form of computation not
the kind of computation that your
Macintosh does but rather a form of
presumably analog parallel fuzzy
computation but computation nonetheless
and that emotions can be understood as
mechanisms of feedback and control a
little bit like your like your
thermostat artificial intelligence has
underscored that intelligence is can be
understood as a physical process by
building computers and robots that can
do intelligent things the most famous
example being the defeat of the world
chess champion Garry Kasparov by the
program deep blue six years ago
neuroscience has undermined the ghost in
the machine through what Francis Crick
called the astonishing hypothesis in his
book of that title the hypothesis that
all of our thoughts and feelings all of
our desires and joys and aches and
passions consist of the physiological
activity of the tissues of the brain and
astonishing though this hypothesis maybe
there's a great deal of evidence that
it's true we know that every form of
mental activity gives off electrical
signals that we can now detect and
moreover that by sending an electrical
current into the brain the person can
undergo a vivid lifelike experience we
know that the brain is a chemical organ
and that
administrations of chemicals such as in
drugs can change perception thought and
mood in surgery if a surgeon severs the
corpus callosum joining the two cerebral
hemispheres then you've got to
consciousnesses taking place within one
skull as if the soul could be bisected
with a knife when a brain is damaged by
strokes and other diseases a part of the
person can vanish we know that the brain
has a staggering complexity a hundred
billion neurons interconnected by a
hundred trillion synapses which is fully
commensurate with the remarkable
complexity of human thought and behavior
and there's every reason to believe that
when the brain dies the person goes out
of existence despite intensive efforts
by a number of 19th century scientists
no one has been able to figure out a way
to communicate with the dead and this
idea is not as new as you might think
but it was first articulated in The
Brothers Karamazov in the scene in which
dmitry karimov is has been visited by a
local medical researcher and is now
telling his brother what he's just
learned he says imagine inside in the
nerves in the head there are sort of
little tails I look at something with my
eyes and when they begin quivering those
little tails and image appears that is
an object or an action damn it that's
why I see and then think because of
those tails not because I've got a soul
and that I am some sort of image and
likeness Rakatan explained it all to me
yesterday brother and it simply bowled
me over it's magnificent Alyosha the
science a new man's arising that I
understand and yet I am sorry to lose
God well indeed people are sorry to lose
God or the values that they associate
with God when they hear of the the new
science there's been widespread fear and
loathing of the sciences of human nature
both from the left and from the right
and an example from the academic left is
the famous manifesto against
sociobiology authored by Stephen Jay
Gould and Richard
Lewton and others I'll give you a quote
the reason for the survival of these
recurrent determinist theories is that
they consistently tend to provide a
genetic justification of the status quo
and of existing privileges for certain
groups according to class race or sex
these theories provided an important
basis for the enactment of sterilization
laws and also for the eugenics policies
which led to the establishment of gas
chambers in Nazi Germany and partly
because of this these accusations IO
Wilson who the author of sociobiology
was hounded by demonstrators wherever he
went to speak in the late 70s and early
80s as we see in this poster from one
college campus Edward o Wilson so coming
here Edward Wilson socio biologist and
the profit of right-wing patriarchy and
at the bottom of the poster it says
bring noisemakers but it isn't only the
left that's been upset but also the
religious and cultural right for example
in the Weekly Standard Andrew Ferguson
wrote that biological theories of the
mind are sure to give you the creeps
because whether a behavior is moral
whether it signifies virtue is a
judgment that the new science and
materialism in general cannot make and
he contrasted biological theories with
the judeo-christian view according to
which human beings are persons from the
start endowed with a soul created by God
and infinitely precious and this is the
common understanding the new science
means to undo this is a widespread
belief among the political religious and
cultural right for example the
Republican majority whip Tom DeLay
offered this the following explanation
for the horrific Colombian high school
shootings four years ago he said that
they were inevitable because our school
systems teach children that they are
nothing but glorified apes evolutionized
out of some primordial soup of muddin
and similarly the US House Judiciary
Committee received the following
testimony from a creationist Institute
about the dangers of Darwinism they
cited the lyrics of the following rock
song you and me baby ain't nothin but
mammals so let's do it like they do it
on the
every channel
well where does the fear and loathing
come from and how might it be addressed
that's going to be the subject of the
rest of this talk I'm gonna suggest that
there are that these fears deserve to be
taken seriously and that they are four
in number the fear of inequality the
fear of imperfect ability the fear of
determinism and the fear of nihilism
I'll explain each one I'll argue that
all are based on non sequiturs all come
from the fact that these this approach
to human behavior is novel not that they
really logically follow I'm gonna go a
bit farther and say that not only does
biological understanding of the mind not
have the dangers that it's been accused
of but in fact there are dangers in
going in the opposite direction in
denying human nature and what this means
is that we should study human nature
objectively without trying to put a
moral thumb on either side of the scale
let me start with a fear of inequality
this comes from a simple mathematical
fact
that's zero equals zero if we're blank
slates we must be equal but if the mind
has any innate organization then
different races sexes or individuals
could be biologically different and that
would condone discrimination and
oppression well I think as soon as you
see the fear stated so clearly you see
the flaw in it namely that fairness does
not require a belief in sameness when
Thomas Jefferson wrote in the
Declaration of Independence we hold
these truths to be self-evident that all
men are created equal he did not mean we
hold these truths to be self-evident
that all men are clothes rather the our
commitment to political equality is a
recognition of certain human interests
that we assume to be universal across
the species as it was written that
people are endowed with certain
inalienable rights and that among these
are life liberty and the pursuit of
happiness it's also a commitment to as a
policy prohibiting discrimination
against individuals based on the
statistics of certain groups that they
belong to such as race ethnicity or sex
that is the core of fairness and
equality of opportunity and has nothing
to do with the factual question of
whether people are all people are
biologically indistinguishable also
there's a downside of denying the
possibility of individual differences
many of the most horrific cases of
racial and ethnic persecution in the
20th century in fact did not come from
targeting groups that were thought to be
racially inferior the problem is that if
you believe that all people are
indistinguishable there's a temptation
to treat the more successful people not
as more talented but rather as more
ruthless or avaricious and many of the
atrocities of the 20th century came from
persecuting ethnic groups that provided
the circumstances that allowed their
more talented members to prosper
examples include the Indians in East
Africa in the South Pacific the Chinese
in Malaysia and Indonesia the Evo's in
Nigeria and the Jews almost everywhere
now the second fear is the fear of
imperfect ability the dashing the
age-old dream and the perfectibility of
mankind and it runs more or less as
follows if unpleasant traits are innate
selfishness violence prejudice rape that
would make them unchangeable so attempts
at social reform and human improvement
would be a waste of time why try to make
the world a better place if people are
rotten to the core and will just foul it
up no matter what you do well this too
doesn't follow the one reason is that
ignoble motives do not automatically
lead to ignoble behavior and that's
because the human mind is a complex
system with many parts and some parts
can counteract others so even if we did
have innate temptations towards
antisocial behavior we also have a moral
sense cognitive abilities that allow us
to learn the lessons of history and
executive systems of the frontal lobes
that can receive information from these
subsystems and use them to control
behavior indeed the more
progress that we have enjoyed over the
past few centuries didn't so much come
from erasing or rewriting human nature
as exploiting a certain part of it the
philosopher Peter Singer wrote a book
called the expanding circle based on the
idea that universally people have a
sense of morality that's the good news
unfortunately the default setting is to
apply it only to the members of your own
clan or village or tribe but that social
progress over the centuries consists of
expanding that circle and deploying the
sympathy that we instinctively feel
towards our own family and friends to an
ever expanding a circle of people we've
expanded it to include all races the
mentally handicapped prisoners of war
newborn children and most recently to
all of humanity as in the Universal
Declaration of Human Rights all of which
could come from taking a knob or a
slider and expanding the application of
the emotion of sympathy outward rather
than recreating human nature from
scratch and there are also downsides in
the belief of imperfect ability and I'll
mention three of them one of them is
totalitarian social engineering if
people are blank slates well the
temptation is to say we damn well better
control what gets written on those
slates because if we don't do it it will
happen by accident and indeed many of
the the most atrocious totalitarian
regimes in the 20th century overtly
believed in the blank slate for example
mouths a tongue probably responsible for
35 million deaths wrote it's on a blank
page that the most beautiful palms are
written the Khmer Rouge which massacred
a quarter of their countrymen had a
slogan only the newborn baby is spotless
and much more benignly but still
troublesome is a quote from the city
planner an architect the Corbusier who
said that city planners should begin
with a clean tablecloth we must build
places
where mankind will be reborn a
philosophy that's sometimes called
authoritarian high modernism the idea
that we could we should redesign
societies using quote scientific
principles now what does that mean in
practice
well this cityscape over here is a
picture of central Paris or at least
what Paris would have looked like if the
Corbusier had been given his clean
tablecloth and was able to flatten it
and rebuild it according to his
scientific principles fortunately he was
not granted that wish the problem was
that um his theory of human needs as he
described it was that every human being
needs so many cubic feet of air per
minute to breathe so many gallons of
water for bathing so many gallons of
water for drinking so many square feet
for sleeping and that was pretty much it
and that's what lead led to his idea
that city should be designed for
efficiency at meeting those needs as
opposed to the chaotic noisy dirty
jumble of cities like Paris that
offended his sensibilities well we now
see where he went wrong that his theory
of human nature was basically the blank
slate
and he omitted many other aspects of
human nature such as the need for
intimate social interaction in
comfortable spaces the universal desire
of humans to be in the presence of
living things and green space the effect
of natural light on mood the need for
ornament and aesthetic pleasure human
scale that makes people feel safe in
dissent defensible spaces and so on and
the Corbusier was not given a clean
tablecloth to flatten Paris and start
all over again one of his students did
design Brasilia which is notorious as
one of the world's great uninviting
wastelands and the theory of
authoritarian high modernism was in part
responsible for the urban renewal
projects of the late 50s and early 60s
in which vibrant neighborhoods were
often
obliterated and replaced by high-rises
and freeways and windswept plazas
another downside of perfectibility is
the lack of appreciation for democracy
many of the totalitarian regimes of the
20th of 20th century were led by
idealistic charismatic leaders who
exerted a claim of moral superiority
over their predecessors as a basis for
their authority believed that their
totalitarian state was just a temporary
measure that would eventually wither
leaving us in a state of anarchism in
which people would benignly cooperate
and live in peace in contrast democracy
is based on a rather jaundiced theory of
human nature the idea that people are
permanently saddled with a limits on
their wisdom and foresight and the
mechanisms of checks and balances were
explicitly intended as a way of
counteracting the natural tendency among
leaders towards ambition and
self-deception the idea is beautifully
captured in the famous aphorism by James
Madison if men were angels no government
would be necessary if angels were to
govern men neither external or internal
controls on government would be
necessary and a third downside in the
belief of perfect ability I think is a
distortion of human relationships
especially parenting now here's a quote
from a mother that appeared in The
Boston Globe on the parenting experts
she said I'm overwhelmed with parenting
advice I'm supposed to do lots of
physical activity with my kids so I can
instill in them a physical fitness habit
so they'll grow up to be healthy adults
and I'm supposed to do all kinds of
intellectual play so they'll grow up
smart and there are all kinds of play
clay for finger dexterity word games for
reading success large motor play small
motor play I feel like I could devote my
life to figuring out what to play with
my kids on top of that I have to be a
short-order cook preparing two or three
meals at a time because if I force my
kids to choose between eating what's
there or skipping a meal they'll get an
eating disorder
well I think anyone who's recently been
apparent and has looked into the
juggling manuals can sympathize with
this frazzled mom now here are some
sobering facts about research on
parenting most studies of parenting are
useless the studies that gave rise to
all of this advice for mothers why are
they useless because they don't control
for heritability they measure some
behavior in the parents they measure
some trait in the children they show
there's a correlation and they assume
that correlation implies causation it
must have been the parenting behavior
that shaped the child in that manner
much of this research doesn't even test
the possibility that parents transmit
genes to their children as well as an
environment and so for example the fact
that parents who talk more to their
children have kids with better language
skills or parents who spank their
children have children who grow up to be
violent may come because there are genes
that predispose children to being more
articulate or more violent there are
studies that do control for inheritance
for example redoing the retesting for
the correlations in adopted children who
do get parenting experience from their
parents but not their genes and here are
the two findings that turn up over and
over again in study after study one of
them is that siblings separated at birth
end up assume a similar as siblings
reared together now remember the malla
for twins separated at birth they bump
into each other at the Patent Office
with identical contraptions in their lab
okay that's one discovery but that's not
the one that I'm talking about here a
second discovery from that research
which is less well appreciated but
equally important is that if the malla
for twins had been had grown up together
in the same house with the same parents
they would have been no more similar
than they are than they would have been
if they had been separated
similarly for biological siblings those
who are separated and brought up in
different homes are no more different
than those brought up in the same home
corroborating that set of
and ones that look at similarities among
adoptive siblings who don't share genes
but do share an environment and find
that they're not similar at all in
adulthood in personality or intelligence
they are no more correlated than pairs
of people plucked off the street at
random well what are the implications
the implications are that the intellect
and personalities of children are shaped
not by parents but by a combination of
factors in part although only in part by
genes in part by the surrounding culture
both the culture of the society as a
whole and the children's own culture
which we call a peer group and in part
by chance trance events in the wiring of
the brain in utero in the first few
years of life and perhaps chance
experience now I found that when people
hear these results which are were first
brought to the public attention by
Judith rich Harris in her book the
nurture assumption they often have the
following reaction so you're saying it
doesn't matter how I treat my children
now it's it may be a natural reaction at
first but think about it of course it
matters how you treat your children it's
never okay to abuse or belittle or
neglect children because that's a
terrible thing for a big strong person
to do to a small helpless one who is
under that person's care child rearing
above all is a moral responsibility also
let's say someone told you that you
can't shape the personality of your
spouse now no one but a newlywed really
believes that you can change the person
nonetheless I'm hearing this bit of
wisdom
no one says oh so you're saying it
doesn't matter how I treat my spouse
well of course it matters how you treat
your spouse it matters to the quality of
the relationship that you have and the
degree of pleasure and respect and a
depth that your relationship will enjoy
likewise parenting is a human
relationship between two people one of
whom is a parent one of whom is a child
and how the parent treated the child in
childhood is going to affect the quality
of that relationship and I think it's a
sign of the influence of the blank slate
that so many people could forget the
simple truth or at least when
intellectualizing they can forget it and
think of parenting only as the molding
or micromanaging of a child's
personality when whereas in fact it's
much more than that
let me more quickly go over the the
remaining two fears the fear of
determinism determinism in the old
philosophy senses the opposite of free
will
runs as follows if behavior is caused by
a person's biology he can't be held
responsible for it and in fact the fear
is not totally groundless here's a
headline that I clipped out of the Wall
Street Journal a number of years ago
man's genes made him kill his lawyers
claimed honest you can insert your
favorite lawyer joke here now by the way
the defense was not successful the this
man's genes did not get him off the hook
but there's a clear fear that in the
future we have to worry about this well
the reason the defense didn't work is I
think fairly obvious comes from the old
saying to understand is not to forgive
standards of responsibility credit blame
reward punishment are themselves causes
of behavior these standards don't have
to appeal to a ghost or immaterial soul
but rather to certain parts of the brain
presumably concentrated in the
prefrontal lobes that can inhibit
behavior we can retain this influence on
the brain systems for inhibition namely
holding people responsible even as we
come to understand the brain systems for
temptation
I'm also the bogus defenses for bad
behavior that have made the news from
our judicial system are in fact more
likely to be environmental than
biological anyway they include the abuse
excuse with which the Menendez brothers
got off the hook in their first trial by
saying that the reason that they had to
kill their parents is that they abused
them when they were children the black
rage syndrome that the radical lawyer
William Kunstler proposed as a defense
of the Long Island Railroad gunman who
began shooting passengers at random it
was because of the stress of living in a
racist society the patriarchy made me do
it defense that some lawyers have used
to try to get rapists off the hook that
they were inflamed by pornographic
images and a misogynistic society and
perhaps that the best example comes from
West Side Story in which the juvenile
delinquents tell the local police
sergeant there's kindly sergeant Krupke
you gotta understand it's just our
bringing the up key that gets us out of
hand our mothers all our junkies our
fathers all our drunks golly Moses
naturally were punks
the final fear is the most nebulous it's
the fear of nihilism the idea that
biology strips life of all meaning and
purpose it says that love beauty and
morality are just figments of a brain
pursuing selfish evolutionary strategies
and a nice illustration of this fear
comes from the following comic strip in
which our hero Arlo is pacing the floors
late at night unable to sleep wracked
with doubt he says to a son why am I
here and the boy says to pass on your
genes you still here
admittedly most people are not satisfied
with this answer to the question now I
have to add that this is not just
although it's often a fear expressed by
people with with certain religious
beliefs it's not just a religious worry
but it's a secular worry as well but
I'll just I'll discuss the religious
version of the sphere and the secular
version separately the religious version
runs more or less as follows that people
need to believe in a soul which seeks to
fulfill God's purpose and is rewarded or
punished in an afterlife now I don't I
want to make it clear that I don't I
don't intend to argue that that against
religion or the people should not be
religious or that there's necessarily an
incompatibility between religion and
science there are a number of brilliant
neurobiologists and evolutionary
biologists who believe that there's
nothing incompatible between Darwin's
theory of evolution or the belief that
the mind is completely a product of the
brain and some kind of belief in a
Supreme Being and I don't want to take
on that debate my goal is more defensive
I want to argue against the position
that only religion is can be the source
of our moral values and here's why in
particular the belief in a immaterial
soul and an afterlife and and here's the
response to that accusation from
religion first of all I don't see
anything so ennobling about a belief in
a life to come because it necessarily
devalues life on earth and think about
what we conclude when we remind
ourselves that life is short or what we
do we renew a friendship we bury a
hatchet in a silly dispute we offer a
gesture of affection
we vow not to squander our time and to
use it wisely I would argue that nothing
gives life more value than the
realization that every moment of
consciousness is a precious gift also
God's purpose sounds good in the
abstract but in
practice it always seems to be conveyed
by human beings and that opens the door
to a great deal of mischief I'm going to
many of you have seen the wonderful
satirical newspaper called the onion
with its mock news stories and about a
year ago they ran the following headline
hijackers surprised to find selves in
hell
we expected we expected eternal paradise
for this say suicide bombers now
admittedly this was criticized for being
tasteless and it is but I think it does
make it an important point namely that
yes it may be true that without a belief
in an afterlife there may be some people
who are not deterred from committing
evil acts by the threat of spending
eternity in hell but on the other hand
they wouldn't be tempted to commit evil
acts by the promise of spending eternity
in heaven now what about the secular
version well I think this is a nicely
captured and the flaws of it are quite
apparent in the opening scene of Annie
Hall in which the young Woody Allen 7
years old has been taken to the family
doctor by his mother doctor says why are
you depressed Alvy this mother answers
for him it's something he read something
you read huh
the universe is expanding
the universe is expanding while the
universe is everything and if it's
expanding someday we'll break apart and
that would be the end of everything his
mother says what is that your business
he stopped doing his homework and Aldi
says what's the point
now clearly Alvey has gone wrong here
and the reason I think is beautifully
pointed out by his mother
frequently a source of wisdom who says
to him what is the universe got to do
with it you're here in Brooklyn Brooklyn
is not expanding
indeed Brooklyn is not expanding the
reason that we that we laugh at this the
reason we laugh at this interchange is
we realize that the young Woody Allen
has confused two different levels of
analysis the human level what is
meaningful to us and how we want to live
our lives today given the brains that we
have and the causal level of how and why
our brains cause us to have those
thoughts to begin with they're related
but they're not the same and it's
important not to confuse them even if
evolution is an amoral process with no
purpose some hope in which genes
according to the metaphor selfishly
maximize copies of themselves that
doesn't mean that people are also a
moral or purpose purposeless or selfish
only the process that led them to evolve
had those properties my final point is
that morality certainly is not a
hallucination or a fiction invented by
our brains but there is an inherent
logic in it that the human moral sense
can be thought to implement a point made
by centuries of philosophers but I think
best illustrated once again in the comic
strips in this case from the late
lamented cartoon Calvin and Hobbes in
which Calvin lays out for us why we
can't abandon morality or treated as
affection by showing the consequences of
trying to do exactly that so one day
Calvin says I don't believe in ethics
anymore as far as I'm concerned the ends
justify the means
get when you can while the getting's
good that's what I say might makes right
the winners right the history books it's
a dog-eat-dog world so I'll do whatever
I have to do and let others argue about
whether it's right or not hey why'd you
do that you were in my way now you're
not the ends justify the means
I didn't mean for everyone you dolt just
me what this cartoon shows is the
inherent unten ability of any system in
which you would try to get other people
to treat you in a manner different from
the one that you are committed to treat
other people that logic the golden rule
if you will is the core of morality and
it's no coincidence that it's been
independently rediscovered by many of
the world's religions and at great moral
traditions so to sum up the I've argued
that the dominant theory of human nature
in modern intellectual life is composed
of the doctrines of the blank slate the
noble savage and the ghost in the
machine that this theory is being
challenged by the modern sciences of
mind brain genes and evolution but these
challenges are also seen to threaten our
moral values but in fact that does not
follow on the contrary understanding
what makes us tick can clarify those
values by showing that political
equality does not require sameness but
rather policies that treat people as
individuals with rights that moral
progress does not require that the mind
is free of selfish motives only that it
has other motives to counteract them
responsibility does not require that
behavior is uncaused only that it
responds to contingencies of credit and
blame and that meaning life does not
require that the process that shaped the
brain have a purpose only that the brain
itself have a purpose
moreover grounding values in a blank
slate is a mistake because it makes our
values hostages to fortune implying that
some day factual discoveries could make
them obsolete and because it conceals
the downsides of denying human nature
including persecution of the successful
totalitarian social engineering an
exaggeration of the effects of the
environment such as in parenting in the
criminal justice system a mystification
of the logic of responsibility democracy
and morality and the devaluing of human
life on earth with that I'll conclude
very much
by phrase and one of the earlier slides
that said study human nature objectively
could you say a few words about that and
how that could be better done by
everyone studying human nature yes for
one thing when all of the questions that
I raised about the blank slate the noble
savage and so on are there empirical
hypotheses that could come out one way
or another we have I think good evidence
for for some hypotheses but ultimately
the only way to find out is to look and
in I think there's been a distortion in
many of the sciences that study human
beings because of a fear that certain
issues are our third rails you touch
them and die and that distorts the range
of hypotheses that are tested and the
studies of parenting are a perfect
example the studies that don't control
for heritability I think come to
misleading conclusions which then get
translated into misleading advice
likewise studies in anthropology I think
that studies of warfare and violence in
non-state societies have been distorted
by the belief in the noble savage of a
fear that if you document rates of
violence quantitatively you'll be
portraying people as savages and
therefore saying that we can't help but
kill each other and people who have
tried to document it often I've often
been shouted down slandered censored and
so on which can only I think harm our
understanding both of ourselves and of
indigenous peoples so those would be two
examples and I think in general it's not
that anything is going to be completely
innate or completely learned completely
learned is almost a contradiction
because you need something innate to do
the learning we should have an open mind
realized that what we learn doesn't
directly lead to any policy but has to
be combined with some statement of
values and democratic means of resolving
them
the more we understand the better we
understand the human mind the better off
we'll be because the wiser our decisions
will be yes how much of this do you
attribute to free well starting from
this heredity and environment and the
individual using his reason to get the
best results yeah well I think the there
is a phenomenon that we label freewill
namely there are some kinds of behavior
that are involuntary your knee-jerk
reflexes and you know particular strong
emotions that we might feel there are
other aspects of human behavior that
first of all can't be predicted with
certainty and second of all are
responsive to contingencies of reward
and punishment and other consequences
it's the ones that are not completely
predictable and that are responsive to
holding people to contingencies of
responsibility that we call freewill the
common belief is to equate freewill with
some soul or entity that's free of the
laws of cause and effect that's what I
consider to be a a mistake but that
doesn't mean that it isn't worth
distinguishing voluntary behavior from
involuntary behavior and certainly we
have to do that to have to have the
maximum deterrence effects in the
criminal justice system you want to you
set up punishments to deter the
behaviors that are most datura Bulow's
are the behaviors that we tend to
attribute to free will and ironically as
dan dennett has pointed out that
realistic practical appreciation of what
we want freewill to do shows that the
last thing we want is the idea that will
is totally uncaused because then a soul
that was truly free of cause-and-effect
could say i don't care if you think i'm
a boorish CAD or if you lock me up i'm
gonna do what i want to do anyway and
that would defeat the purpose of holding
people responsible you want there to be
some predictability
if only statistical predictability so
that holding people responsible
we'll have the effects that you want yes
in the future it may be possible for
technology through implants or some
other technique to take over more and
more of the operation of the human brain
and possibly the mind however you want
to define that do you think that that is
possible and if so what would be the
implications for theory such as yours
yeah it would be
I'd be very foolish to say that anything
is impossible but I don't think it's
very likely I think it's easy to get
carried away by some of the techno hype
of roboticists that you know any
sentence that begins you will or it's
only a matter of time before should
arouse strong suspicion the human mind
is extraordinarily complex we don't know
yet how to duplicate anything in any
aspect of the mind in detail nor do we
have anything close to the technology of
a literal implant in the brain that
would control the the mind or substitute
for thinking there are so many boring
practical problems like how do you keep
electrodes in place given that the brain
is floating in fluid and moves how do
you prevent scar tissue from forming
around the electrode and it could be 400
boring reasons rather than any reason in
principle that a lot of these science
fiction predictions are unlikely to come
true and my guess is that although it's
worth pursuing especially for clear-cut
cases like restoring movement to people
who are paralyzed that it might be worth
pursuing but the idea that there's going
to be a kind of a you know Terminator or
Robocop scenario in which silicon will
actually replace high-level neural
tissue I think is unlikely yes thank you
I've just started reading your book so I
guess you may have answered this
question in the book as I go along and
get to the last pages but how do you
respond to the question of adaptability
of genes to circumstances
in the sense that our genes immutable
over a certain period of time because
that goes against the whole evolutionary
theory itself so therefore because I the
reason I'm asking this is immutable
heredity is often used as justification
for relative wrongs like racism for
instance and it's often used as an
argument supporting inequality based on
genetic immutability to circumstance
well genes are only immutable in the
sense that Lamarck was wrong and that
our experiences don't aren't reverse
coded back to systemic changes in the
DNA that then get passed on to future
generations they're of course not
immutable in the sense that they're
constantly prone to mutation and
recombination but the I believe I
addressed your concern in the part of
the talk in which I discussed that in
equality and that is that if someone
believes that there are innate
differences among individuals that
racism is justified then they've made a
horrendous error that a commitment
against racism is not a factual belief
that people are indistinguishable it
better not be because people are not
indistinguishable and we don't want to
say that class prejudice or racism or
sexism are justifiable and the reason
that we can have both a study of human
differences and a commitment to equality
is that equality is a policy not an
empirical hypothesis and it's a policy
to recognize rights inherent in all
human beings and it's a policy to treat
them as individuals and not to prejudge
them by statistics of a particular group
that they belong to yes I enjoy reading
both Wilson and Gould and I remember
Gould attacks on Wilson and the New York
Review of Books and they always seem
more like debaters posturing rather than
a scientist at work and I couldn't
figure out why he was to my mind so
deliberately and
according Wilson in a perverse way in
order to win debating points what was
going on in in that I I mean I I tend I
tend to agree with your assessment and I
document that in the in the book itself
I think that that Steve Gould and and
the other signatories of the manifesto
and the other attacks on on now Wilson
realized that it was threatening certain
way of justifying political ideals it it
threatened the utopian politics that
were popular in the early 70s and late
60s according to which nothing prevents
us from redesigning society to be better
except a failure of will that there are
no built-in limitations on human nature
that would stand in the way of a utopia
with perfect egalitarianism and
non-violence the idea that people might
have emotions that erupt in violence or
that people may not be people have a
hereditary endowment and therefore it's
possible for them to very in small ways
threatened I think this kind of utopian
politics and a lot of the the heat that
came from this debate I think really
came from these political concerns which
required therefore demonizing the
opponent to make sure that no one was in
danger of taking them seriously it was
thought that a greater good was at stake
you didn't mention Freud or Jung their
psychoanalysis but it probably fits into
your scheme somewhere which other
categories would that go under well
Freud certainly did not believe in a
blank slate and he
hee hee his theory endowed the mind with
with many drives and motives and with
with subsystems like the super-ego and
the it and he also his theory resonates
with one of the themes that I've
emphasized tonight namely that the human
mind consists of a number of competing
systems some of them that tempt us to do
antisocial things and others that might
suppress those temptations I think where
Freud differs strongly from what most
personality psychologists believe now at
least those who followed behavioral
genetics is the idea that how your
parents treated you in the first six
years of life shape your personality and
adulthood moreover which I think has
been refuted by the studies of adoptees
and twins that show that the effect of
the home of the parents is very small to
negligible moreover the idea that was
popular made popular by Freud namely
that psychopathology can be traced to
parental treatment has been very clearly
refuted the idea that say schizophrenia
comes from mothers who convey mixed
messages to their rat child damned if
you do damned if you don't that that
turns a child into a schizophrenic or
that autism is caused by the
refrigerator mother who is emotionally
cold and distant from the child
hypothesis made popular by Bruno
Bettelheim
in the Freudian tradition we know that
these are wrong that these conditions
have a genetic component and they have
some other cause which is not genetic
not how you were raised
and a an important scientific mystery
yes how do you expand on the fortunate
notion that biology always seems to be
associated with the negative which seems
to deny strong findings of biological
anthropology such as reciprocal altruism
and things along these lines where
biology has biological factors have
significant positives
yeah yeah it's it's certainly true that
traditionally biological approaches to
human nature have been perceived as
pessimistic as as giving us a tragic
view of humanity of emphasizing our
flaws probably going back to the
characterization of nature is red in
tooth and claw now I think that to some
extent this is is justified that a
belief in perfect ability of humans and
a blind eye to humans self-deception and
ethnocentrism and so on are our mistakes
were better off acknowledging the dark
side of humans the better to cope with
them than to wish them away because it's
just depressing
too depressing to think about on the
other hand you're right that if anything
the most sophisticated versions of
evolutionary psychology have also shown
that the the better angels of our nature
as Lincoln put it also have an
evolutionary basis such as emotions like
sympathy and trust and gratitude and
guilt and that collectively make up what
we call the conscience that those are
part of our endowment from evolution as
well and in fact there's a whole field
of psychology a new field called
positive psychology founded by Martin
Seligman who's also sympathetic to
evolutionary psychology that tries to
identify what what went right in in
human brain evolution and to get people
both as individuals in their own lives
and perhaps collectively to take
advantage of the of the better angels of
our nature
yes I don't know if I have a simple
question because I may be confused about
some elements that you try to put a get
across here or and perhaps you can
amplify a little bit more you had toward
the end you had ones that was you had
one slide when you had a slide on which
you state but quoting what you said that
selfish gene
do not make for sell for a certain do
not necessarily you don't even use the
word necessarily you say do not make for
a selfish person yes but you don't
necessarily my question is well if it's
not the gene in fact I think you added
it's a process that may turn one human
into a selfish person but if that's so
then we should be concentrating on the
process not so much on the gene and what
brings my point I think home to me is
that your last answer to the question to
the person who asked about your opinion
on Freud and so forth or how you fit him
into this scenario into your scenario
bothers me a little bit because you
immediately discounted his theories and
coupled him with Bettelheim now
Bettelheim is not freud he may he
post-dated him but that doesn't mean he
improved anything no he has been
discounted and discredited in many ways
chiefly or I might just repeat order
system is not a psycho analytical
condition schizophrenia and you did
mention Freud in that with that term
it's not a neurotic at least for my
understanding a condition so what we
when we talk about Freud and
psychoanalysis I don't think we really
are talking Ament to talk about it's a
frame in schizophrenic but rather
neuroses that certainly do I think Freud
showed you originate and childhood and
at least be a either nurtured or for
stood and childhood and that's a process
you see it's not inherent in the human
in the child initially it's a process so
on I don't know if I'm confusing you
with my coupling The Selfish Gene
needing a process to explain what
happens to turn a person into a so a
selfish person with your comments on yes
well the comments on sigh you're right
in that my comments on psychoanalysis
were really on the psychoanalytic
tradition including the thinkers that
post-dated freud including Bettelheim
and and others and it's true that Freud
himself did not have the refrigerator
mother as a theory of autism but
Bettelheim did working in a Freudian
tradition and and modifying it but I
think Freud did set the stage for a
movement that was dominant in psychiatry
until recent decades they did try to
seek the roots both of psychosis and
neurosis in early childhood certainly I
think even most Freudians now would say
yeah you can have psychosis we're not
gonna look to early childhood for that
find its its genes and other causes it's
not even clear to me though whether
neurosis can be attributed to a child's
relationship to his parents in the first
six years of life I know that the belief
is widely held and it's often the basis
of psychoanalytic psychotherapy but it I
don't think it's been properly tested
and I think the studies that do bear on
it suggest that for it may have been
wrong about the neuroses as well that it
probably is not the way you were treated
as a child but some combination of genes
and something else that's not genes but
that is not also not parental treatment
yes one just one point where you're
talking about I'm having a little phone
logic of your argument when you're when
you say most of the studies done on
social factors and parenting for example
or bad studies and then and then you go
to these studies that link it to
genetics and say our goods
those are good studies what's the
criteria you're doing that on and and if
it's not identified with a specific gene
how you know to me you're kind of
measuring a constructs so how do you
make that evaluation I guess oh it's
simple I mean it's just the usual
criteria for social science research
namely that you shouldn't attribute a
correlation to causation until you
measure plausible third variables that
could explain the correlation in this
case variable a is parental behavior
variable B is children's traits the the
bad research simply interprets the
correlation as a causation a causal
relationship better research would at
least measure the possible third factor
genes to see if it can be attributed to
that as opposed to the putative cause
namely parenting now that's it's not the
end of the story because simply knowing
that sharing half a genome has some
causal effect it doesn't tell you how it
has its causal effect and I expect that
the major new area of research over the
next few decades will be trying to get
more specific about which genes do what
at what stage of the developing brain
where they expressed what do the gene
products actually do to flesh out the
causal story right now our measures are
crude but without a measure of possible
effects of the genes you're just people
would just be committing the elementary
logical error of confusing correlation
with causation causation with statistics
but you could be leaving out some other
factors too is my only thing you seem
like okay you put it hereditary stuff
and now you've answered the question
when you could possibly leave out other
things and you're never showing
causation you're making that assumption
when you can only prove correlation
right well the in in the case of genes
there is you can rule out some of the
possibilities because we know that say
that growing up in the same home for
example it being similar can't be read
back and change your DNA so that kind of
correlation can only go in one direction
because Lamarck was wrong but again
that's not to deny your point that it
leaves a lot of things open and moreover
I should add that this the research that
I'm referring to also measures other
factors besides family parental behavior
and genetic relatedness such as possible
effects of the child on how the pair
treats that child as opposed to other
children so the individualized parenting
that a parent might give to one child
and not another causing to children in
the same home to in fact have slightly
different environments also needs to be
measured and the few of the most recent
studies do measure it but come to pretty
much the same conclusions that is that
once you control for genetic relatedness
then differential parental treatment of
one child to another seems to be a
consequence of the fact that the kids
are different to begin with they don't
seem to add any additional measurable
effect on how the children turn out but
that would be an example of other
factors that ought to be and sometimes
are measured hey take off one more or or
no boy end it no I think I've been asked
to I in the evening to switch over to
the reception in the book signing sorry
for those of you who had questions and
thanks very much for your
Steven Pinker is author of the blank
slate
the modern denial of human nature number
ten on this week's New York Times
bestseller list it's published by Viking
an imprint of penguin Putnam visit
penguin Putnam com for more information